en el vídeo anterior nos quedamos en el
león arcaico
ar que proviene del griego y significa
comienzo u origen y este es el león en
el que la vida comenzó a existir o al
menos comenzó a florecer y es posible
que tal vez la vida empezará a existir
desde el final de león hadyan o porque
recuerden que esta división es algo
imprecisa y además el eón arcaico
también es el primer león del que aún
tenemos rocas actualmente aún podemos
encontrar rocas de esta era que tienen
aproximadamente 3.8 mil millones de años
ahora otra cosa muy interesante que
ocurrió en el eón arcaico y que tiene
una gran importancia cuando llegamos al
león proterozoica es que empiezan a
surgir las cianobacterias las cuales
producen oxígeno y en el vídeo anterior
dijimos que en ese tiempo la mayor parte
de ese oxígeno producido por las
cianobacterias era absorbido por el
hierro en los océanos pero cuando
entramos en el león
soy co que es el que tenemos aquí ahora
nos encontramos en el león proterozoica
proterozoica que empezó hace
aproximadamente 2.5 mil millones de años
y la palabra proterozoica proviene del
griego y significa vida temprana bueno
no se me da muy bien el griego si alguno
de ustedes sabe griego disculpen si no
estoy dando la traducción exacta pero
bueno lo que es muy interesante sobre el
león proterozoica es que el oxígeno que
ya se estaba produciendo por las
cianobacterias en algún punto empezó a
saturar el hierro y a cualquier otra
molécula que podría haberlo absorbido
antes y una vez que eso pasó empezó a
ser liberado a la atmósfera
entonces el oxígeno empezó a ser
liberado y empezó a acumularse en la
atmósfera y se dice que esto ocurrió
hace 2.4 mil millones de años entonces
hace 2.4 mil millones de años
oxígeno empieza a acumularse en la
atmósfera y bueno estas fechas pueden
moverse algunos cientos de millones de
años conforme encontramos más y más
datos pero esto es lo que se sabe hasta
ahora tal vez en el futuro revisaremos
el registro geológico y registro fósil y
esto cambiará un poco pero yo solo puedo
imaginar que dentro de 50 o 100 años si
alguien aún ve este vídeo muchos me
digan oye pero después encontramos que
el oxígeno empezó a acumularse en la
atmósfera desde antes o después o
kellogg's eucariontes surgieron antes o
después pero bueno hasta ahora esto es
lo que sabemos y lo que les puedo decir
es que hace 2.4 mil millones de años el
oxígeno empieza a acumularse en la
atmósfera y lo más interesante sobre
esto es que una vez que el oxígeno se
acumula es decir una vez que se logró
tener una gran cantidad de oxígeno en la
atmósfera hace aproximadamente 2
es mil millones de años ocurrió algo
llamado el gran evento de oxidación a
veces también se le conoce como
catástrofe de oxígeno y eso ocurrió aquí
hace 2.3 mil millones de años o 2300
millones de años la atmósfera se volvió
rica en oxígeno no como en la atmósfera
que tenemos actualmente pero se volvió
lo suficientemente rica en oxígeno para
que el ambiente fuera idóneo para los
organismos de células eucariontes ahora
otra cosa interesante aunque tal vez no
nos interesa mucho porque nosotros
necesitamos el oxígeno es que se cree
que esto fue la mayor extinción de la
historia en la tierra por eso se le
llama catástrofe de oxígeno hace
aproximadamente 2.3 mil millones de años
ocurre la mayor extinción de la historia
de la tierra y eso fue porque las
cianobacterias produjeron tanto oxígeno
que se saturó el hierro y el oxígeno se
acumuló en el aire
y una vez que se logró una gran
concentración podríamos decir que
incluso empezó a sofocar porque el
oxígeno era venenoso para muchos otros
organismos en el planeta que eran
anaerobios es decir que no necesitaban
el oxígeno para ellos el oxígeno fue
venenoso pero como ya teníamos oxígeno
ocurrieron dos cosas muy interesantes
claro además de provocar esta extinción
masiva bueno en realidad fueron tres
cosas dos de ellas fueron cruciales para
que nosotros hayamos aparecido en el
planeta
mire la primera es que el ambiente se
volvió idóneo para que las eucariotas a
las que también llamaremos eucariontes
pudieran existir recuerden que las
eucariotas son organismos que tienen
membranas nucleares alrededor de su adn
y la mayoría de las eucariotas tienen
otros organelos cómo la mitocondria
necesitan oxígeno necesitan oxígeno los
invito a que vean otros vídeos en los
que hablamos de la respirar
qué ocurre en la mitocondria y que
obviamente es un proceso que necesita
del oxígeno entonces ahora que el
oxígeno estaba presente en la atmósfera
se logró un ambiente en el que los
eucariontes pueden existir y basándonos
en el registro fósil y analizando cómo
ha cambiado el adn con el tiempo se cree
que las primeras eucariotas surgieron
hace aproximadamente 2.2 mil millones de
años aunque hay un poco de debate al
respecto porque hay evidencias que
demuestran que pudo haber ocurrido un
poco antes o un poco después así que
seguramente ese número se redefinirá en
el futuro pero bueno lo que pudo haber
pasado algunos millones de años antes o
después de eso fue que una célula
procariotas engulló otra célula
procariotas y se dieron cuenta de que
les iba bastante bien viviendo juntas y
actualmente la teoría es que la
mitocondria proviene de una célula
procariotas antigua de una bacteria
incluso tiene su propio adn así que el
adn de nuestras mitocondrias pasó a
nosotros de nuestra madre y de la madre
de nuestra madre y de la madre de la
madre de nuestra madre y así
sucesivamente y es una pequeña célula
viviendo adentro de una célula más
grande entonces como nuestras células
son eucariotas necesitábamos que esto
pasara y recuerden que el cuerpo humano
no es solamente una célula eucariota
estamos hechos de billones de células se
estima que entre 50 y 100 billones de
células eucariotas y estos son los
ancestros que surgieron en ese momento y
claro todo esto ocurrió en los océanos
ahora otra cosa interesante fue que
bueno recuerden que en este tiempo había
un bombardeo enorme de radiación uv-b
proveniente del sol
entonces si analizamos la tierra déjenme
dibujar la tierra y el océano aquí
tenemos el océano
y esta es la tierra entonces la tierra
constantemente es bombardeada con
radiación uv-b es decir radiación
ultravioleta
por eso la dibujo de color morado
constantemente es bombardeada con
radiación ultravioleta proveniente del
sol y eso es muy inhóspito para el adn y
para la vida así que la única vida hasta
ese momento pudo haber existido en el
océano protegida de la radiación
ultravioleta porque la tierra estaba
abierta a eso todo lo que había en la
tierra era irradiado el adn habría
mutado y un organismo no podría haberse
mantenido con vida así que lo que pasó o
al menos lo que se cree que pasó y la
razón por la que ahora somos capaces de
vivir en la tierra es porque ahora
tenemos una capa de ozono en la
estratosfera que ayuda a absorber o
mejor dicho que bloquea la mayor parte
de la radiación uv-b del sol y ahora que
el oxígeno empezaba a acumularse en la
fuera y que ocurrió la catástrofe de
oxígeno el oxígeno se acumuló tanto en
la atmósfera que una parte subió aún más
en la atmósfera ahora nos encontramos en
este periodo
entonces el oxígeno empezó a reaccionar
con la luz sube y se convirtió en no
solo con lo que empezó a bloquear esa
luz sube por eso está producción de
oxígeno fue muy importante porque creó
la capa de ozono y así tiempo después la
vida pudo existir en la tierra y no
solamente en el agua y también fue muy
importante porque los organismos de
células eucariotas necesitan el oxígeno
ahora la tercera cosa que ocurrió y que
también fue un evento muy importante es
que se cree que el oxígeno empezó a
acumularse en la atmósfera y reaccionó
con el metano el metano es un gas de
efecto invernadero que ayuda a retener
el calor en la atmósfera pero una vez
que reacciona con el oxígeno y sale de
la atmósfera
y así fue como la tierra empezó a
enfriarse y entro en su primera y más
larga glaciación que es lo que tenemos
justo aquí la primera glaciación en la
tierra que también se conoce como
glaciación hurón yang y eso ocurrió
porque bueno si la teoría es correcta no
se pudo retener el calor y se dice que
toda la tierra se congeló entonces
conforme avanzamos en el león
proterozoica lo más importante es que
por primera vez hay una atmósfera rica
en oxígeno es la primera vez que los
eucariontes pueden existir porque ahora
hay oxígeno para respirar y otra cosa
muy importante es que se forma la capa
de ozono y eso deja todo listo para el
siguiente e ón en el que los animales o
por lo menos los primeros seres vivos
llegan a la tierra pero hablaremos más
sobre eso en el siguiente vídeo